oh did we forget to have something hello
and welcome to the Friday games review
I'm your host Dan Galpin and myth with
me once again is Ian nee Lewis filling
in for Co cam that's right Koh's got
very important work to do so she's
leaving us to drink beer and play games
without her and speaking of games there
are five on today's list our crash
tastic physics puzzler spider feeder
that's right
I'd have to click the button yeah
deceptively simple Domino x4
subliminally races sorting game Metro
rush unfortunately named match 3 game
booty quest and space ball and speaking
of beer I think it's definitely time to
open some up absolutely hot wow that was
great
so we're we're experimenting with having
a scripted opening which for most of our
shows has worked really really well but
this time two issues first I finished
writing the script
at 3:02 yeah and second Dan sitting here
like a jerk holding the button where I
can't see it and I don't even going
what's going on exactly back up because
I have things to say speaking a beard
okay so today's beer is green flash
Brewing Company's double stout black ale
excellent excellent
yeah by the way I can't go back to that
slide because one of the one of the one
of the really cool things if you have a
slide OTO go forward you can't ever go
back to it ever again with the clicker
you have to you know way yeah it totally
prevents you from doing it it sucks yeah
exactly
alright so yeah I definitely need us
right definitely need this beer today
hey Edie we had we were going to spend
thousands of dollars on teleprompting
equipment yeah but then we were like
we've got a Mac you know he knows needs
a little bit of work by it's one beta
tester I still think nice right
dan Pham we were going to blame beer on
him but he says he didn't buy it all
right actually don't know who did all
right
stealing someone's beer wearing green
flash shirt but I'd not bring that beer
in although I will vouch for it is a
great double stone yeah yeah well I
definitely liked their IPA which was I
think was called palate wrecker the girl
named for an IPA
so you'll notice we're broadcasting
today in space yes exactly um let us
know what you think about this because
they're been haters yeah I'll tell you
we we put this black background up
because we thought it looked you know
kind of boss yeah well look it looks
really really good when you guys have
the lab coats actually I like it yes
that's right that and by the way and the
reason I'm wearing this hoodie is
partially just so I can contrast a
little bit more against the black
background you know we put up a massive
massive hair light just to catch the
highlights just to do yeah the high
highlights off my skull that's always
good we have a common already obi-wan
droid obi-wan droid nice all right
well alright so what I have producer day
but engineer Dan's gonna be watching the
comment stream because we're too lazy to
make him do very much work in fact today
is the end of the quarter for us we've
been working on performance reviews
which for me means putting it off and
Dan Galpin means once again writing a
great review for me let me attempt in
the attempt yet again mm-hmm to get me
promoted as I am the Susan Lucci you
know the it was it was mostly that that
we have all of our reviews are due at
exactly 11:59 and 59 seconds last night
and I was there until 11:59 and 59
seconds still making comments so and
then I was filing bugs after that so
it's been it's been a long night and so
it was a great time to go we were very
excited about getting to this crop of
games because I really needed some
distraction from all of this and hung
over so let's go ahead and take a look
at our first game oh wait we
no the first game is booty quest we can
I know I had yeah you see the order
that's right yeah in the script I just
put him in the order that their names
were funniest yeah I can't believe you
put booty quest first alright well you
know it it was talked like a pirate week
last week so and booty pod says the
chain you guys can't hear the audio
because the audio for booty quest we can
we can bring this up now the audio for
for booty quest is actually kind of epic
it really does have lots of great
pirates stuff in it yeah and I and I
love their listing page this is actually
a really really good way of doing a
listing page you know they have the
taxes of great size it's very very
readable you know immediately this is
gonna be a match for jewel game it's got
it's got some great characters in it my
only my only you know looking at at the
at the actual listing my only thing I
would want them to change be the icon
because I see no reason to have a giant
rounded corner thing when you've got
there's a really cool bird character
that you could totally have pop and in
fact out of the only game the only icon
I really liked out of all the games was
baseball we can continue to go on this
though alright so let's get to the
actual booty quest why is it's a metro
rush wait we'll stay in booty quest ah
better okay are you I screwed this up
totally alright and we to one other
problem we have to actually plug the
tablet in so let's let's look yes we do
because the tablets not what I've been
that's why it's - I know I know there's
two inputs but we're not actually making
taking advantage of that so seriously
why did I spend all the money on that I
know I know
hey I just saw we do we totally do all
right let's let's plug this in and let's
actually get in come on that's actually
get into booty quest if it's like
alright we're tuning out right now these
guys are jokesters man actually knowing
our audience this is probably when
everybody's gonna tune absolutely they
were like they were like oh this is so
cool these guys all right so I'm a
couple things to note here on booty
quest first of all there's some really
nice effects the game has got actually a
really great graphics and when we are
playing it in HDMI mode we've got this
giant green line on the on the right
hand side of the screen which is really
kind of sad are you serious that's not
us that's not no no that's actually that
actually the game itself so you know
everyone really on Android you have to
always make sure that that your game
really does need to do something
reasonable when you're at 1.33 aspect
ratio all the way up to one point seven
seven yeah you know it's like and also
you can't just look at the size that's
coming back from the display because you
actually have to look at the size of the
screen you're given and sometimes this
may actually be that problem that's a
really common thing to go on with games
is people say hey let's pull the size of
the display let's ignore the view that
I'm actually given assume that I'm
working for fullscreen and I'm just
gonna get the whole thing you just can't
you can't do that you're not always
gonna get the full screen especially on
these tablets although we did actually
make a change the original honeycomb
tablets would actually give you the full
screen size and that's screwed everybody
up there like wait so and so in order to
make things slightly easier we do only
give you the window now that you're
gonna render in but you know if you're
plugged into HDMI you're still not gonna
get all of that all right so now let's
go over to engineer Daniel who's waving
his arms frantic oh it's like no one can
hear you Dan where audio is completely
cutting off I'm actually just interested
in trying some beer oh it is it is
really good I know by the way we're
gonna do a short show today um because
two of these games crash and four of
them suck so that's not sure I wouldn't
I wouldn't go that far actually only one
of them crashes on both devices one of
them actually only runs on the phones we
are gonna switch the phone just to be
nice and show that one don't see why Dan
gets promoted and I don't reviews and
I'm sorry it says metal rush this really
isn't metal rust this really is called
the game is fun I mean honestly I like
match for games there are better match
three game the Magister sorry match
three games we call it I don't know why
I refer to it a match for game it's it's
it's a jewel matching game it's got its
really really well done the animations
and transitions are smooth there's some
special things going on there's
explosive gems
you know the thing is this category is
so full there are so many jewel matching
games on
great example of a jewel meshing it is
yeah there are a lot of them well know
what let's take it on its own terms
absolutely I like the the animation is
great I love that it's got a little bit
of reactive physics mom when things get
removed you know feels like they're kind
of blowing up and you know when they
fall down they're getting you know
there's there's definitely some math
going on here and I love that yeah and I
get also professional absolutely the
game is just really really fluid and it
is really actually fun to blow things up
with the gems you know it's so you know
definitely my hat's off in terms of game
I always say the only thing is in terms
of depth there are some super super deep
matching games out there with all sorts
of different scenarios that are really
complicated and you know there's even
like like one of the ones we actually
looked here which was rise Atlantis
actually takes you through this epic
quest as you go through the you know
with all sorts of different side things
going on so you know this is a really
really full category but you know this
game is very good I mean I I see no
reason why why it wouldn't be a
candidate for being featured
it does it does reasonable things in
terms of the handling of the back key
one of the things that um but not
everywhere like for example not here but
one of things that does not actually do
is it does not correctly target multiple
display so we still have the
compatibility zoom button available it's
not targeting a new SDK version so we
still have the menu showing up and we're
still having we're still having like
j'ni compatibility stuff thrown in so
there's a lot of there's a couple things
I liked in the change I'd also like to
make sure that they're actually
correctly targeting the screen yep great
stuff so let's go ahead and talk about
metro rush so yeah mr. rush interesting
you know at first I couldn't actually
figure it out yeah and then what I did
figure it a little bit yeah the fact
that you're sorting different colored
people into different colored cars yeah
yeah it's regular mode south will rise
again mode I don't see so we get this
get this train yeah and you'll notice
that the train has a very small little
green thing so now yeah we gotta sort
all of the green
reen people into the car yeah
and you know I think it's supposed to
represent the route that they're going
on but it just so happens it as you're
playing it all the green people look a
lot alike
now we're in our orange orange people
yeah and they all have a different race
I don't know why that's the a bead you
know this is oh there we are we did we
have to be to have to be wasn't sure
yeah yeah but it is sort of interesting
puzzle did the orange guys were like
Irish I think I think you're right yeah
exactly
so you know a lot of I mean one thing
about this a couple things about this
game one is it yeah it definitely needs
sort of an intro to be like what am I
doing here it is kind of weird if you
missed the train they just kind of stand
on top of the Train which I kind of
liked yeah but it's a little buggy yeah
and let's face it this this mechanic has
done been done before it's been done
better witness I call up the my favorite
thing is this at the bottom like that
like like the five guys that are all
like I like standing off each other at
the bottom of screen but yes it is a
little buggy the other you remember that
bathroom game where you know they had
the men women there was like dogs and
there's Android yes that was a good
sorting game this game you know I mean
maybe if you're three mmm
well the other and I'll say some other
things to note you can see that there's
a real real problem with this particular
screen size and resolution you can see
the richest retry button and a quit
button really squashed and this actually
goes to be happy we have you brought to
be fair this isn't an easy resolution
it's not a common resolution in common
aspect ratio yeah it's it's it's just
the resolution used by every single
Android tablet out there oh no no this
isn't oh yeah yeah this would this one
to HDMI excuse me yeah but even outside
to make sure my motors still squat well
what I'm yeah so what I'm saying though
is that yeah you know the particular
aspect ratio that we're looking at is
extremely squashed because we're in HDMI
mode but it's a little bit weird but let
me pointing out here okay sorry go on
so this is this is actually their
listing and the listing also has a
completely squashed in different aspect
ratio from the actual my my point really
is that you know as I mean phones are
getting longer yeah aspect ratios change
you know there is no device on the
market that I'm aware of that that will
guarantee always being the same forever
yes
with Android the nice thing is that at
least we've you know thought about that
and gone through the pain so that you
can okay we have a new rule right at no
static slides for more than five seconds
so any let's go back but I just wanted
to show that because it was sort of it
was sort of and I didn't want to
actually mention that that that this is
also not a particularly good listing
page like you know it doesn't know it's
not although but it is representative of
the game at least which is good there's
a lot of listings that aren't but anyway
to be fair what I guess what I was
trying to say is we you know Android
gives you the tools to deal with these
aspect ratio changes and especially when
you're doing vector graphics there
really shouldn't be any reason to make
these mistakes yeah yeah I think now
I've said my piece yeah no that's good
and down I'm gonna shut up now I have a
really important question from someone
in the YouTube oh yes oh yes important
the question is how can you play with
beer how can we not play with a beer
yeah I think that that's a harder that's
that's okay you tried this game don't do
it in a dry County that's all I'm saying
all right well I think that pretty much
says it all
yeah there's I mean there's there's some
good ideas here it definitely needs to
feel more fluid you know my basic
feeling my basic complaint with this
game is it is actually and I think part
of it is the aspect ratio like I think
it is having trouble I'm dealing with
touches and with handling the characters
on this particular screen you know it's
just you know when you're doing a
sorting game like this yeah now and I'll
tell you what the main problem is with
the mechanics piece let's talk about the
things they did right right okay yeah
did vector graphics of vector graphics
look really what really good so those
turned out well yeah they did they're
higher I think they're high-res graphics
that have been rendered new they're not
I don't think they're actually vector
here I think they've just been rendered
into bitmaps but yes well you know the
the basic game idea there's nothing
wrong with it I would say that the
interaction is a little difficult a
sorting game like this you probably want
to have a little
momentum physics mm-hmm so that it
doesn't turn into a laborious dragging
game
well enter your fighting the interface
more than yours and that was gonna say
it's on a phone it's also bad because
you don't to drag it far but when you
soon as you get to a tablet if you don't
actually have the physics built into it
then you really are just be like oh I'm
dragging this thing across the screen
well yeah how many times Dan made this
same mistake do you leave let go just a
fraction of a second too early
mm-hm and instead of getting in and
giving you points dude just you know you
hit a bug basically I just like yeah
sits on top of the Train looking weird
um it's really really soft and runs them
all over by the way which it does do but
you know there's no there's no like
running over yeah yeah okay kind of fun
yeah anyway I this is some great
programming no question about it is this
it's not finished
yes not a finished game yeah it needs
more work all right let's move on all
right so our next title in all of this
and I want to go back Tori this this is
this is this was this was the fun one
for us this is a game that we actually
were unable to get to run an enterprise
yeah we were excited were like well
actually looking at the listing we
weren't particularly excited no I'm
really stoked away in their video look
at okay okay looking at the listing I
wasn't sure um you can see that that if
you had this on a device you would never
be able to read the text it's it's just
it's just it's and I can't read it from
here which is well I can read the title
barely you know the and part of the
problem to you is that they haven't
differentiated the title on the tagline
like if you look at it let's say a movie
poster the title is big the tagline is
small it's a good tagline
yeah those tag lines go by derp is
hungry you have to feel you have to feed
okay
but instead they're it's like spider
feet of the spider hungry you have to
feed it it doesn't look like a listing
it looks like a meme yeah yeah so so
this game failed to load because it
couldn't actually get a class that it
needed which caused its main class to to
not load so you know all we're gonna
have is a green-skinned I want to show I
will show you what happened I will long
I will launch it here and you'll get
unfortunately spider feeder is stopped
yeah
unfortunately it's the you know when you
have a class that is from the main
activity class it prevents the main
activity class from loading but you
can't see what it is because it because
because you just say oh the main
activity class failed to load because
one of the things that's depending on
wasn't there so you should be able to
see in the there's there's like the
really long listing and you get down to
the bottom it should it depends on it
depends on where it's trying where it
crashes unfortunately in this race it
yeah I did not s trace it so this this
was just I just used like run on it yeah
you probably wouldn't gotten much out of
it without streets unfortunately it's
might say yeah this is all this is all
deck stuff so that's trace would just
let me know it was trying to load a file
Asterix is really cool though if you're
trying to debug native stuff it's
actually really really useful to know
where which call your app made that
caused things to crash so you know
definitely thumbs up a nest race we
actually made a nice update to it to
that tool in the last in the last six
months so haven't used it recently
thought oh oh yeah yeah we're we're very
close to being able to install jelly
bean on our little transformer prime
here which is very exciting and I'm
hoping it'll work because that'll be fun
but you want to do it right before the
show just in case something went wrong
how could that happen yeah exactly are
you really surprised yeah be shocking um
so the next app we're gonna actually
look at its Domino x4 and this is
actually this game is are really
beautiful because I write is this a
deceptively simple game it is actually
on it just seemed like I didn't I hadn't
even played the game and just you know I
was writing the script from like
dominoes I bet it's deceptively simple
yeah this is actually it's actually
really fun um it's it's a puzzle game
that the time-based game here's what the
listing looks like which is actually
pretty good it's pretty representative
of the game you see we actually get some
nice because it's got green on it we're
getting some green screen showing
through with our with our little
presentation ooh yeah you can see us
behind there and I would still like the
text to be slightly larger and you know
I just that font I've never liked I you
know for this kind of thing but you know
it's fun yeah
but now it's you know that's it's
everyone's taste
however we actually get to the game
itself and I'll launch it here on the
tablet and you'll see why this game
we're actually gonna switch to the phone
first of all menu looks fine I mean not
exciting the text you can see is kind of
small that's because we're any wearing
up and the so is the domino and that's
because we're on an mdpi device and and
on you know these things just look huge
on an mdpi device when you're actually
looking at and how do I make my app
scale for the tablet sometimes it makes
sense to actually select a different
resource type and you can actually do
that so that's what's one thought here
and we actually go to new game and you
can see wow I deceptively simple okay
this is um it's just not playable no
this is awesome
oh my god best game or best game ever
how do I play it what do we what do we
do to rotate the Dominos and as you can
see unfortunately it's like a Nyquist
game
unfortunately the oh yeah this Domino
doesn't just affect itself
it affects dots in other dominoes as
well so unfortunately we're seeing here
is that the the matrix that's being used
to scale the bitmap is just not correct
for this screen size and resolution and
so we're just we're seeing the dots
they're actually all over overlapping
each other and in a game is not it's not
playable but because we are trying to
make sure that you guys can actually see
that how the game is played we're now
going to switch from the tablet view
you'll you'll see us lose this
momentarily to our trusty Galaxy Nexus
all right yes and although we have this
great like on-screen animation
everything looks really smooth yeah
that's a result of you picking up a
court off the floor
yeah and plugging it in and I know I'd
end Daniels firework so here is here is
Domino and here's what it looks like now
there is there are some rendering
problems even on Galaxy Nexus you can
see that it's cut off I'm not sure why
this is actually the case because it
doesn't actually happen but it happened
at this point I don't even
what I'm looking at yeah so what's
actually going on here is you're seeing
a couple of rendering problems it's
worse with the HDMI IN because you're
getting a slightly different screen size
there as well if you actually get it
fullscreen it's less cut off but as you
can see at least we can see the game to
play it so we can rotate the Dominos
so that though that's so that they line
up and the goal is to get blocks of
bricks of dominoes that line up together
this is actually really hard to play
with HDMI because I can't see that how
many dominoes are how many how many dots
are actually on each Domino I'm not sure
honestly I I have to look at that there
layout you know if I had a little more
time I would have actually tried to pull
apart their layout and see why it's
wrong don't lean against that God how
many times I have to tell you so soft
though you've got a soft velvet
background this thing looks black but
it's actually black and squishy as soon
as I got my glow-in-the-dark paints
yeah actually I'd like you know black
light that'd be kind of cool to do a
black light it was out are you rockin
yeah we should totally do that yeah
since we're about to be swamped with
zombie games that it's true what mades
ambe's a thing why are zombies such a
big deal I you know I think it was the
zombie head that the bet that PopCap
created for plants vs. zombies I really
didn't like that I guess they spend like
3 grand making this zombie head and it
becomes this viral video I mean it that
it's like that in Gangnam style you know
like that's right what we're gonna see
it Halloween and so it's safe to assume
that neither of you guys have a zombie
kit prepared at home right I do actually
I was on be kidding okay just in case
zombie invasion I'm Ryan totally
separate off a shotgun he's making four
zombies though no communists no in
earthquakes actually but I it's
earthquakes slash zombie invasion now
hmm my parents had a communist kid came
the commie invasion
all right so let's let's switch back to
the tablet I just wanted to show that
actually when it without HDMI it was
much much more playable so I'm kind of
sad you guys can't see the game because
it's actually really really fun you're
actually matching different tetrominoes
together with the dominoes and so it's
actually it's actually a very very
clever game so yeah when you're the
lovely
spawned yeah it's totally that's totally
the lemmings fun heard the name but I
think it's Cooper no that's Cooper
Cooper's though as the other plate it's
um it'll come to me I usually it's not
copper plate nobodies it's Cooper black
that's right it's not compromise its
Cooper black that's what it is
yes ha doesn't that might sound like a
whiskey it totally should be a could be
like what you'd be great to make a
cooper black whiskey if it actually had
the font on the on the front all right
so we're going to go to our final game
which lasers space ball unlike the rest
of these we had no idea how to make a
joke out of this name we're playing with
balls man oh come on all right this one
actually is our only landscape game yeah
mr. pham all right high five to our
engineer man this is he's he's been
kicking some serious booty going to
we've got some real problems here we've
got like a much more professional set up
yet we're not professional at all what
happened to the producer Kim yeah
where's the producer can put over there
actually we oughtta plug to him I
disconnected it so we can have a bow
tablet and phone available yeah we don't
we don't we actually so we have all
these cameras but we don't have a power
strip that we actually have the extras a
lot of that extras a socket for it so we
could plug both at the same time I think
I don't think the fire marshal would be
too happy with our electronics setup see
that there's a power strip on the floor
of this and nothing plugged into it or
that it's actually true there's there
several in this room right it's
completely safe anthem has a power strip
over there that could probably handle
like a new area that thing is amazing as
like that is seriously kicked butt it's
meant to it's meant to power soldering
irons and and heat guns and we have it
here for powering laptops and phones
right all right so spaceball first of
all I want to say well it's not space
balls it's baseball its space ball right
okay licensed property yes just in case
you were curious this is even though it
looks exactly the font seems like and
actually it feels very cartoony very
much like the movie this has nothing to
do with the movie
can you thinking about Spaceballs I
think you think about MBA AGM so so
there's a serious problem here though I
mean look at this it's a you're not
gonna be I know this actually our our
new studio set up is really useful for
this because we are actually about 10 to
12 feet away from a very very small
monitor showing this and in terms of
like our radians it's about the same
size as what it would be on a phone yeah
I was like I cannot make heads or tails
out of this it looks like next to the
character and and the thing is that the
writ would be fine at that size if there
was more contrast but right now with the
amount of contrast there is between its
baseball logo in the back it's actually
very very difficult to read remember the
weirder your font the lower your
contrast the bigger it needs to be in
order to be legible
yeah and it's such a great logo I would
really like to see that you know I'd
like to see just a little bit more
contrast between the the text and the
background other than that great this
icon by the way wins the icon award of
the week as I said hell yeah this is
what an Android icon should look like
other game developers take note right
seriously oh yeah move on so I can see
your yeah other game developers take
note there we are
yeah otherwise he's gonna mess you up
look at him yeah in the hood that's why
he's got a hoodie absolutely with what
with the antenna on it yeah yeah
actually kind of fits for this game so
uh you know this games go oh yeah I'm
that dude from Assassin's Creed now oh
you totally are man you're from the
future
and this isn't even your Assassin's
Creed hoodie you act no it's not yeah I
do have an assassin's Creed II is not
nearly as good for playing yeah exactly
okay space ball so um so so space ball
is a shooting game and it's actually
kind of a shooting gallery basketball
game which is really cool you sound so
disappointed it's a shooting game it's a
shoe it's a basketball shooting game
like but you know it's well done it's
actually it's actually really different
I like the little animations it's not a
lot of not a lot of frames animation but
they're there you're going you at your
goal
to line up the shot into the mascots to
be kidding me oh my god and you get
points for getting like runs you don't
want to get them into those things cuz
you lose your ball you in now I'm
screwed because I lost my ball kind of
highly advanced culture is responsible
for this I totally screwed that up so
then you have to drop the ball and now
I've dropped it far away from him so I'm
screwed as far as I know I can't get it
yeah I can't get it back
what dude can't like walk over and just
get it I don't thinks maybe you can't I
never figured that out lazy are you
little purple dude I know why was trying
to tilt oh you tell him okay there we
are actually again totally flummoxed by
an accelerometer yeah I know I know
not to mention have we lost you'd be
lost HDMI by the way where we have the
I've decided I hate micro HDMI with a
passion I hope we never put in product
but you realize that consumer connectors
are not meant for this stuff I know I
know I know okay that makes the game way
more fun I was like trying to figure out
I'm sitting here playing with this on
the desk being like this game seems
really not very dynamic so that's
something that I'm not gonna say that
that your typical but still no I know
it's always nice to add a little bit of
discoverability ah
die die stick ball that was cool
this stuck ball gave me a basket so
anyways I actually the aim is really fun
I would like to the accelerometer
mechanic to be a little bit easier found
and I actually don't think this game
needs an accelerometer
it's all it games that that have
accelerometer where they don't really
need one drive me nuts it's a general
rule now there may be there is a way to
change the controls maybe I can go back
and if there's a way to say I mean I
think you could make the argument that
you know you need one hand for shooting
and you're but the problem is too is if
you actually know this is I'm gonna ran
for a second here's a problem when
you're doing accelerometer stuff mm-hmm
that takes a hand he needs at least one
hand and it feels better with two hands
yeah now at the same time let's say that
you need to touch the screen in a in its
specific place yes impossible you know
why cuz you're tilting the device all
over the place do you see how hard I'm
trying well it it definitely makes it
way on a tablet this game gets on
because could be that it's one thing
when you have a mechanic where there's a
couple buttons on the side of the screen
that you can get with your thumb while
you're you know twisting it around
mm-hmm but if you have to move your
device and do any kind of precision
touching that's gonna be frustrating for
most of your users well you know what
kind of device they have yeah and the
other thing is in general accelerometer
games on tablets you know have to be
really really carefully thought through
so that would be my only my only
comments is if you've got to do one you
know first of all it's better have it
it's better have multiple control
options anyways we've already shown that
you know if you give people the options
to have different controllers they'll
love you if you don't oh man
I totally want to get that trick work
simplify your control I mean do you
really have to control the way this guy
runs it's obvious where he's gonna run
to maybe you should think about making
that yeah make making a mode where he
just goes and grabs it although it is a
nice - TNT yeah laughs Oh mm-hmm
that was bad um case the but I love the
different game modes in the game I
actually really like the the game is is
totally cool in the way it plays I
actually would like to see it not use an
accelerometer because it changes the
control screen the the graphics are nice
the animations nice it's got you know a
fun mechanic it's not super deep but
it's interesting yeah I want to see
higher res graphics admittedly like this
is a kind of game I can imagine you know
taking a bar just like make some bets
over just kinda happy and you know
trash-talking with my friends oh man I
bet you can't make this many baskets or
whatever and yeah I know it's totally
quiet I want it I would love to see kind
of a social there is social stuff built
into the game but you know there I'm
sure it can be taken further actually I
don't need a social stuff built into the
game mm-hmm oh so hey come on and we're
so yeah I mean uh it does have gree
built into it I don't actually know if
it enables any social nodes because I
think it's because well I see these
things I'm like I don't like fun so so
anyways yeah but spaceball I would like
to I definitely like to see some higher
res graphics it does look really blocky
tablet and on a phone it's okay but
otherwise the game does really well and
actually it actually for the most part
you know yields to our guidelines except
except here we're hitting the back yet
you'll see where a guideline yeah yeah
that's way of routing it submits to our
guidelines it becomes out something I
can it does I media meaning meaning that
you know as an Android user you're
mostly not gonna be in order that now
this is totally annoying
come on gree make the back key actually
do something useful in your app
seriously like look at this the only
time I've seen the game crash right
inside agrees stuff what is up with that
you know that's a perennial problem and
let's just remind everyone that although
middleware gets things wrong all the
time it's your problem if you put
middleware in your game and it screws
something up and you don't get featured
because of that don't write to us and
say oh but it's my middleware can't I
get a free pass no you can't ya know
where is the one that's grabbing
everyone's phone numbers and saving them
in an evil database so that overlords
can contact you by SMS no man it's your
middle it's still your fault you know
that's like I'm sorry
exactly I and the truth is our hands are
kind of tied right we can't take your
middleware out
that's your decisions to take it out or
put a minute put it in yeah sorry I
respect it with a kind of style i but a
long week ah if you if you choose to put
in middleware that doesn't work or that
does something wrong that's just as bad
as putting a you know programming a bug
into your game alright so let's go ahead
and take a look at our live stream
engineer dan what are the people saying
out there we've got a bunch of different
comments but we do have a question from
Owen okay so Owens asking can you guys
try to explain how to scale some of the
art using matrices for different screen
resolutions so there's a couple ways of
doing it I mean you give you if you're a
view based game you can actually using
canvas no node if your view based game
like if you're if you are one in which
you're actually using custom views you
can use image view you can use a matrix
associated with that you can actually we
actually it's kind of
nice we would give you a matrix that
actually had that has multiple different
kinds of transformations and we actually
give you a bunch of functions to allow
you to create the matrix without
understanding the matrix map present
kind of glory by three matrix and if you
don't understand the matrix math you'll
never need be able to debug it yes
that's true and the functions don't
always work the way you think they
should and the moral of the story is
learn math oh yeah and actually if you
go to ian's has a really really great
code sample that he did which is part of
Android U which is his custom view code
sample which actually goes through using
matrix math to do a bunch of
transformations including you know
including rotation and scaling right
that is yeah that's somewhat true you
cut it down a lot because people said oh
you know maybe it's a little too hard
yeah maybe you shouldn't expect people
to know math I think that was I think I
think that yeah that might um yeah yeah
Ian had a much better example to lose
more lose more man yeah but the
important thing remember that a three by
three matrix
encapsulate s-- I pretty much the any
any mapping between the two by two
spaces right so for an XY coordinate
system you know three by three matrix
you can do translation rotation scaling
skewing perspective etc mm-hm and
building that matrix is something that
our functions will do for you
mm-hmm but concatenated matrices
together also something that will do but
you need to understand how the math
works in order to make sure that you're
doing it in the right order
matrix multiplication unlike most other
types of multiplication is non
commutative which can really trip people
up witness the incorrect math that was
actually in our open jail pebbles yell
sample yes which was a tricky one
because there was not only bad math but
there was a memory overwrite that we
didn't catch we made it look like it was
good math yes certain conditions yeah it
actually it actually looked like it was
doing something reasonable which is
always dangerous question ever yeah
totally and I have to say by the way
Joe and I both wrote responses and his
was like oh yeah it's wrong I'll fix it
and mine is like well here's how it's
wrong here's the fix blah blah blah blah
but he mentioned that he was the guy
that wrote the sample so his God
accepted no stackoverflow reputation
isn't exactly the best in the world you
could always go exactly and he's the man
come on look at you both 'i fix the math
the main thing is that yeah you're
applying a scale matrix to to your
bitmaps in order to fit them into a
specific place but it seemed like you
know either the scaling was wrong or it
was being applied in the wrong order
because as you're rotating things they
were being scaled way out beyond the
bounds of where we thought they should
be so the yeah I know if that helps
answer your question yeah I mean I not
then signed on to office hours on
Wednesday you can ask us live my general
my end yeah the one more thing I like to
add is that it's it's is that it's
really important
since the matrix can do all those
transformations use the matrix for all
of them don't try to say well I'm gonna
put this thing in a surface view and I'm
gonna try to set a scale factor
somewhere else oh yeah yeah since
they'll I rely on the matrix to do
everything one it's really fast and and
and two it actually will make your code
a lot simpler well you got to remember
to what's going on here right I mean the
software line the matrix I feel like I'm
in a movie or something like that yeah I
know
so the thing is I remember that you know
obviously for software rendering this
doesn't matter but for Hardware
rendering anything that's done using the
matrix will be done by the GPU I'm sure
there are some exceptions that but
that's a general rule whereas if you do
something without using the matrix it's
a bit of a crapshoot you don't know if
you're gonna get it or not now there are
some things you need to be careful of
for instance let's say that you draw a
path and then scale it using the matrix
and we'll be very fast but the quality
will be low because we draw GPUs aren't
very good at drawing paths so we draw
the path in software and then scale it
up or scale
down which means one of my favorite
things to do in the old system which was
to always draw paths in a 1x1 box and
then scale it to whatever didn't know
bad that that would be a sad thing yeah
but for things that are already drawn
you know bitmaps text especially things
that can be scaled and rotated by the
hardware you know make sure that you do
that of course it's a little bit more
complicated than just using the canvas
matrices you also have to make sure that
you're in a layer and my my class on do
custom controls in so Android developer
done Android comm slash training I think
yeah anyway I have a class on on doing
custom controls and it explains how to
draw something to a layer so you can
very quickly rotate it and get buttery
smooth graphics even though the
operation that you're doing is kind of
and the other guys who should look at
his class actually are the guys who did
the Metro rush game because his game his
his gait is a custom control actually
talks about physics and he actually has
some very very nice fling physics in
that and I think that would help the
game out immensely and you can actually
use the built-in physics model you get
with our gesture detector to to do a lot
of that so and the other people who
should look at my class is everybody
come on sorry me wait to get him promote
it it's very important alright so
anything else on the live stream other
than so I mean fans like hey there's
some comments oh and here's something
I'm actually gonna read to you yeah
here's what we can actually to read read
on the air right I'm not exactly sure if
you guys answered Owens question yet but
he posted a little
we am poorly yes yes so let's say I play
I blame the Stout specifically he says
yeah we don't know exactly what they did
wrong in the domino games bro come on it
he's saying I say you design your vector
art in 480 by 800 res now you want to
have support for a large screen HTTP i
phone say like 1200 by 600 resolution
okay he's looking for the technical
details on how to scale that I'm not
sure if you guys addressed that okay so
it there's kind of two different things
um you know if your vector art you're
importing it as a bitmap oh yeah we
imported yeah that's one really
important thing are you are you doing it
as vector or you know you said bitmap so
that's who's gonna author that yeah so
in general there's AG yeah so in general
if you can't actually display vector art
in your game then what we generally
recommend is exporting a relatively high
quality version of it and putting it in
a higher density to start with that
helps the phones like the galaxy nexus
that are xhdpi because you'll end up
with getting getting high resolution
artwork on there now the bigger question
is how do i how do i do the same thing
on a tablet there's a couple of
different ways of doing that one way you
can do things and this is this is fairly
straightforward is you can actually you
can actually throw the artwork into a
node and into a node epi folder and you
can just try to select you can just try
to select a scale factor that makes
sense don't rely on the system to scale
it at all you can also from lower menu
right into one other problem on the very
low-end devices with with memory because
you're gonna be loading in potentially a
lot much larger set of bitmaps and it's
designed to take which is parched part
of the reason why we do all the DPI
based loading that we do we haven't you
want to try and load whatever is close
enough to your DPI as closest your DPI
as possible and that's the systems can
take care of that then what so here's
let me try and break down yeah well
we're talking about matrices right as
Dan says matrix anytime he wants to
sound smart so here's what we're gonna
do all you're going to do is scale this
but the important thing is there's
two ways to scale a bitmap in Android
you can use a draw bitmap and give it a
destination rect that's different from
your source rect and that will do
scaling or you can draw it to a canvas
at its original rectangle and apply a
scale matrix to the entire canvas and
the problem comes when you mix them okay
so when you mix the two techniques now
well no because of applying the scale
matrix to the canvas is applying at each
drawing operation centerfold so what we
were suggesting is that you pick the
canvas size that you feel is native so
whatever your you had in mind now
remember this isn't gonna take care of
aspect ratio all right it's gonna take
care of size and for aspect ratio you
need to make some other you need to make
some other decisions you may want to do
a little bit of letter bottom you'll
move some some of your your UI elements
out further looking like that and the
other thing that's little tricky is on a
tablet so normally what we what Android
does if you haven't you know and let's
say an xhdpi resource right and you try
to load it onto a tablet which is an
mdpi device
you know androids automatically to go
and it's going to squish that down and
it's going to make an mdpi size because
its goal is it's trying to retain the
physical size of that bitmap which for a
lot of actual non game UI is very nice
because what you really want in a tablet
often is just to display more
information however there's a balance so
what you can do is a couple of things
one is you can actually say you know
what I'm on an extra-large device let's
not use the DPI that is built into it
you can actually say I'm on Al extra
large screen device I'm gonna take use
I'm gonna make use of higher resolution
assets and you can actually set that
until the resource load or actually go
load me the next level up the other
thing you can do is if you're if you're
going to do that a lot you can simply
store your resources in a no dpi folder
and then do some calculations yourself
to determine how to scale because
actually if you look at what's going on
inside of the resource loader all of
it's doing is it's telling the bitmap
factory to scale now one thing that's
kind of nice you can also do if you want
to do it a little bit more optimally is
that there's actually two ways
in which unloading you can scale bitmaps
well but the thing is I think when we
were talking about the dominoes and this
is this is why I was going yeah yeah
matrix direction where they I mean I
think I feel like we're sort of
diverging into 200 stories right the
problem was not that I nobody I'm sure
he was loading the wrong resource but it
felt like the real problem was he was
drawing the Domino's with with one set
of scale factors anyway yes drawing dots
with the others that's right exactly and
the other thing is that the dot the
Domino's alert Brian there we've got
that we got the DPI saying we got the
matrix thing let's separate those and
finish one of those can't talk about the
DPI thing so yeah so for dpi you know
you've got kind of two problems that are
fighting each other you want to make
sure that you make video memories to
work on devices that have limited video
memory so you do kind of so where it
makes sense to do what is going on with
the standard transformations it does
make sense to use them or to simply
apply similar ones yourself the second
thing is that you really want to make
sure that on a tablet if you want to
display things bigger that you do select
larger size larger resolution assets and
and you know the easiest thing to do is
simply to enumerate the kind of assets
you have and select the right one that's
what a lot of a lot of game developers
do try to reliably the API had thing too
if you're in the DPI folders you can
basically work in dips right you don't
have to work in actual pictures that's
correct you can you can do all of your
layouts and dips the only problem with
that is that obviously this thing has a
much larger amount of dips and so and so
you're gonna actually want have
different resources people don't want to
have like hdpi slash extra-large
resources that's actually the correct
way of having different scaled resources
is to actually have separate bitmaps
that are for tablets for hdpi
and for phones for hdpi and you know
that that just gets kind of messy so so
you know they're you know in this case
became a keep the image really small in
order to keep things relatively simple
you'll probably want to do a little bit
of math just to make sure you get the
right size images with the highest
quality available for these mdvi tablets
right so let's move on to that then yes
the way you could do it if you're
especially if you're thinking in dips
right so the dips are sort of supposed
to be related to physical units yes and
so they are actually right well yes
they're related yes they're not I know
they're not a so related
so the trick here is that a four inch
phone and a 10 inch tablet may actually
have the same number of pixels but a
different number of dips so I think what
we're suggesting is that you might want
to go ahead and decide on a sort of
native set native dimensions and dips
and then either expand or contract by
setting a scale factor now how do you
set that scale factor well you do it in
the matrix of your canvas and you make
sure that in for all of the elements
that are supposed to be occupying the
same physical space in your game board
that matrix needs to be the same and the
domino game is probably using one matrix
for drawing the triangles and using
another matrix for drawing the dots and
that's where they're running into
problems I think so I think that's
exactly what's going I think actually
it's probably drawing the triangles as
based just purely on on what's coming on
the screen and it's probably loading
it's probably loading the bitmap images
and making assumptions about the size of
them and then trying to scale about to
scale those that's my that's my guess we
see even saw in Galaxy Nexus with that
device with that game that even going to
HDMI and plugging that in made the game
unplayable so there's probably some
calculations going on that are based on
the display size rather than on the
viewport size that's given as well so
there's probably probably a number of
different issues you have to really make
sure that when the system tells you know
rescale your viewport you really have to
go and redo those calculations yeah
that's very important as well so you
have to remember that you're gonna be on
a multitude of different devices and
this is actually where 3d games have a
real advantage because 3d games are sort
of used to having to do viewport
mappings are you mapping from your 3d
world into a what we call clip space but
2d games a lot of times haven't had to
deal with that unless you're coming from
a background of games that were actually
written to be resized on let's say a
desktop PC yeah and there's no reason
why a game like dominoes shouldn't be
you know resizable and scalable and
there's a lot of ways to to attack that
so I think I think that's maybe that
helps a little bit um you know again the
only dozen if not you know
drop something on stackoverflow and
it'll get to you for your G+ and yeah
well totally do the work you need you
need some more reps so you know yeah
hill-hill hill-hill be there and towed a
while anything else on the Internet
yeah so this is a last question one of
our users wants to know if we have any
guidelines on dealing with performance
variety between devices because the
filtering only handles GPU and screen
size so yeah there's there actually is
it doesn't really handle GPU it handles
OpenGL ES version and at hand and it
doesn't really more about it handles
texture from it is a sort of proxy for
GPU but not a very good one so today
there's kind of two things there's two
low-hanging fruit that you can use one
is of course you can say whether or not
you're actually using OpenGL ES to check
that the second thing you can make sure
that you're actually you know filtering
an OpenGL es2 right um the second thing
you can do is to make sure is is if it's
kind of this is sort of a bad option for
a lot of games but if that are if you're
only using dalvik but the vast majority
of performance bound games are actually
using NDK so make sure to only build an
arm v7 a binary and or mips and tell
binary
don't don't target arm v5 you'll you'll
eliminate a lot of low-end devices that
way all right so now your but now you're
in the issue of I've got this super
super super high performance title that
I know can only target the top 10% of
devices galaxy s3s
galaxy s2 s and if you're in that
position there is nothing you can do
other than to go through and and
eliminate those devices based upon our
pad it let's talk a little bit about why
why this is an issue okay
remember that Android isn't isn't unique
in this I mean like you know in the
desktop space is actually pretty normal
mm-hmm but Android does have actually a
couple more GPU vendors than what you'd
find in the general desktops basically
and we often get the question like well
why don't we just publish some
statistics like you know what's the fill
rated now there's some problems there
first already lies high
and those who aren't lying are only not
lying because they're bad at something
else okay so you can talk about Phil
right and you can talk about polygon
throughput you could talk about raw
vertex shader you can talk about memory
bandwidth but the truth is on a GPU all
of these things add up into something
that's even only partially the picture
because you also have not only do you
have different bandwidths and different
fill rates and different you know
arithmetic unit designs
you also have completely different
architectures so the main ones being
either tiled or well immediate mode and
there and there's actually two things
there's tiled deferred mode and there's
immediate mode which is sort of a yeah
and so so so basically the question the
question you have to ask yourself is you
know one how many devices you so passed
up an opportunity yeah
the question you have to ask yourself is
do you feel lucky punk exactly do you so
how many devices do you really want to
hit you know you know today you know I
think I think you're gonna want to hit a
pretty large cross-section of devices
but you might be limited because of
memory you might be limited because of
just raw GPU power today on Google Play
if you're really limited by those things
and I you know might might and my advice
to everyone just try to target as broad
as possible you know you're gonna if
you're running a 3d game you're gonna
you're gonna have a MIT map with
different versions of a texture for
things that are in the distance
typically take advantage of that and use
different NIT map levels I'm gonna use
mine it biased you know back yeah you
know I don't think there's anybody
that's - that's terrible at vertex
performance yeah so you can think in
terms of you know you you want to have a
certain number of vertices and you can
cut off you know like this year's or
last year's devices I don't actually
think there's even been that much
progress in this but yeah Phil rate wise
you know what's the right thing to do
well Dan's got a good idea I mean if
you're if you're bound by input you know
doing doing omit bias would definitely
reduce the amount of memory the GPU is
consumed in hey that's me that doesn't
reduce the amount the the Jeep
he was producing that's great where you
would introduce your frame buffer sauce
so the second thing you can do you know
if you're really targeting and we know a
lot of developers don't do this and I
think it's partially cuz they don't know
it's kind of hidden but one thing that
you as a developer can do if you're
using OpenGL is you can actually set the
size of your viewport in our windowing
system so not even in OpenGL we actually
offer this sort of hidden API which is
inside of surface holder called set
fixed size and if you do that it'll
actually automatically scale your
viewport up to the size of your window
so it's actually very very useful
literally and and that's done inside of
surface flinger and it may even be done
with a hardware composer so it may so
for a lot of reasons we definitely
recommend doing that especially you know
if your choices are rendering to a pixel
buffer or actually rendering to using
this you should definitely use this
you're gonna get more performance a lot
of times when things are really just
heavily fill limited that's what you
should do obviously there's shader
effects there's other things you can do
but my you know my general advice on
Android is try to make things scaleable
try not to cut off you know users if you
absolutely can avoid it you want as many
users as possible to see your game give
yourself some knobs so that you can make
adjustments don't necessarily expose
those to the users but you know well one
of my favorite games is actor that does
this is dead trigger you know I mean
like dead trigger has a slider and a lot
of with a lot of it a lot of GPUs it'll
detect and it'll say you're guaranteed
to work at the lowest quality only but
you can slide it over and you can save
and turn on effects and you can see what
happens and sometimes it may just crash
the game you know when you when you when
you actually try to run the game with
everything turned on but at least the
user knows I turned on those effects
it's crashing that's not good for every
developer so developers like I'd ever
want users to ever see my child will
crash I much prefer being given the
option of saying let's try turning it up
and seeing what happens and they do it
and they do a whole bunch of techniques
they actually don't even use resolution
in that in that slider they're they're
simply turning off effects they're
they're they're changing to almost all
turning off well remember the things
that are and texture and texture
changing might have texture fetches are
going to be
a big deal hmm on many GPS especially
many many Tyler's state changes are
going to be a big deal on forward
renderers a tegra is the the best
example of this your geometry sorting is
gonna be a big deal want to take
advantage of the early Z rejection on
Tegra it's absolutely critical the
number of games we look at that that the
draw in the reverse order and end up
getting really slow performance of a neo
you know girl let people like wow this
game is amazing a nexus 7 they look at
the next game they say well this isn't
very good and the reason why often is
this developer hasn't taken the time to
design there's kind of two things design
artwork and also make sure that they're
doing draw order that allows for early Z
to really take best advantage of the
hardware now remember that all of the
GPU manufacturers want games to look
great on their particular chipset and
they all have armies of people that want
to help games look better on that chip
sets so if you're having specific
problems contact Nvidia contact Qualcomm
contact imagination technologies I get
some help in fact arm yeah yeah contact
arm not any of these and and you know
get some help because a lot of times
it's just a matter of you know rewriting
a shader or changing your draw order
around and don't forget that all of them
have really great tools yeah for
investigating what your draw calls are
doing
I mean perf ID the adrenal profiler the
the PVR trace all these guy all of these
tools are really really helpful and the
best part for me the exciting part is
that a lot of them now work on non
rooted devices so you can even you know
your consumer devices you can plug them
right in profile works that way Torino
profiler works that way PVR tune is
slowly getting there I mean the thing
with PDR is that you'll run into weird
goofy performance bugs with PVR like you
know your things that you just don't
expect because it's because it does all
of these crazy optimizations for you and
you do one thing that trips it up and
says oh crap I have to render everything
now and all the sudden you wanted to
play we wouldn't limit that to be
no no everyone does that butBut P but P
V R because it does so many
optimizations you may be shocked that
one little operation you dot you do
causes things to suddenly slowed down by
orders of magnitude right right is it
well you know remember wind up night and
they fell over the performance cliff
exactly on our Molly because that was a
driver bug in that particular case we're
know what's gonna happen we're on these
are different absolutely
we're larval BB o--'s which normally
help performance actually hurt them so
yeah absolutely so there are some
general best practices but if you really
really want to push the envelope then
you need to actually purchase some of
these units talk to the manufacturers
and tune for each type of GPU but
remember there's not that many there's
Integra series the audrina the arm Molly
and the PVR
yeah and or a couple others but we don't
you know there's not yeah there those
those are the ones that have volume I
mean you certainly even also in term of
gaming in terms of gaming but I mean
certainly you can go and grab you know
Broadcom devices the galaxy Y uses that
you can grab a Raspberry Pi if you want
to play with with the Broadcom device
and and then there's also some devices
that are now using the Marvel which is
evolved the Devante accelerator the new
co-star from vizio uses that so there
are you know there are a few but again
the vast majority of your phones and
tablets are out there we love all of our
devices here at Android but there are a
few that are made for gaming and some
that aren't so yeah the top four you
really need to look at the others you
know it depends on how broad you want
your audience to be yeah absolutely and
you know again if we're talking about
bleeding edge performance altum Utley
you might end up being a being in a
position where you're actually gonna
have to target the game individually to
different different devices we really
like to avoid that you know my general
my general guideline is do as much as
you can to try to make sure the game is
playable in some form so all right well
we are coming up on an hour now yeah and
I think we are just about done and
engineer Dan wants to get back to his
life yeah and we're out of beer so oh
crap gonna call it a day
mm-hmm yes it was great having you with
us thanks very much for tuning in we
we'll be back next week we are playing
with the format of this show because we
started out as a revue show we want to
introduce some games we hadn't seen
before and now we kind of feel like
maybe we'd rather do a little bit more
engineering it's always been a developer
focus show and we're thinking maybe we'd
like to do a deep dive on some games I
have performance problems or design
problems so let us know what you'd like
to think of course you can always
contact us on the Android developers
Google+ page or if you want to send us a
personal message on G+ too we may
actually see that yeah I never no
absolutely it happens and with that
let's say let's go ahead and play yeah
and definitely continue to nominate
application interested in saying you
know you and you can even say look this
application would be just awesome if it
performed better that's great we'll take
a look at it we'll try to figure out why
it doesn't perform faster so you know
again you know let us know what you want
to do what you want to see this is your
show no it is it's kind of your show now
yeah it's it is there's on but there's a
moderator page continue to nominate
things you want to see on the show and
have a great weekend everyone it's right
kamal little android little android land